JASON: WANT TO PLAY A GAME?
WANT TO PLAY A GAME WITH
EVERYONE IN TIMES SQUARE?
[CROWDS CHEERS].
I'M GOING TO GUESS
ABOUT HOW OLD SOMEBODY IS,
WITHOUT EVEN LOOKING AT THEM.
THINK IT'S IMPOSSIBLE?
CHECK THIS OUT.
I'M GOING TO ASK YOU
TO CLOSE YOUR EYES,
AND WHEN I SAY GO,
RAISE UP ONE OF YOUR FEET,
AND TRY TO KEEP YOUR
BALANCE AS LONG AS YOU CAN.
WESTON: ALRIGHT, SOUNDS GOOD.
JASON: WANT TO
PLAY ALONG AT HOME?
FIND A SAFE SPOT, JUST
IN CASE YOU STUMBLE,
AND GET READY TO CLOSE YOUR
EYES AND PICK UP ONE FOOT.
WE'LL PUT THIS
COUNTER ON YOUR SCREEN.
WHEN YOU PUT YOUR FOOT DOWN,
OPEN YOUR EYES
AND CHECK THE TIME.
ARE YOU READY?
WESTON: YEAH.
JASON: THREE, TWO, ONE, GO.
HIGHER.
LONG AS YOU CAN!
NICE JOB, KEEP IT GOING.
GIRL: THIS IS HARD.
JASON: DOING GREAT,
AAANNNNND.
WHAT ARE YOU LIKE A
YOGI OR SOMETHING?
INGLING: I'M ZEN!
FOCUS, I'M GONNA GUESS
YOUR AGE AFTER THIS.
TRY NOT TO HOP IF
YOU CAN AVOID IT.
KEEP IT UP, KEEP IT UP,
KEEP IT UP!
YOU'RE DOING GOOD!
RACHEL: AHHHH.
TRYING TO KEEP IT TOGETHER.
OH MY GOD, (BLEEP).
JASON: OKAY, TIME'S UP!
HOW'D YOU DO?
CAN YOUR SENSE OF BALANCE
REALLY PREDICT YOUR AGE?
SIX SECONDS, YOU'RE BETWEEN
FIFTY FIVE AND SIXTY FIVE.
MAN: I'M 59.
JASON: 51 SECONDS,
MY FRIEND.
YOU ARE UNDER TWENTY FIVE.
AND HOW OLD ARE YOU?
WESTON: NINETEEN.
JASON: ALRIGHT!
YOU LASTED ABOUT 23 SECONDS,
YOU'RE ABOUT 30 YEARS OLD.
AND HOW OLD ARE YOU?
RACHEL: I'M 29.
JASON: WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
HOW DOES THIS GAME WORK?
STAY TUNED, I'LL GUESS YOUR
AGE AND SHOW YOU HOW YOUR
BRAIN USES SENSES
IN ASTONISHING WAYS.
JASON: OUR SENSES ARE
HOW WE DECODE AND INTERPRET
WHAT GOES ON AROUND US.
AND FOR EVERY ONE OF US,
IT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
OUR SENSES GO WAY
BEYOND BALANCE.
WHY DO SOME OF
US SEE THE WORLD?
MAN: THIS ONE MIGHT BE
A LITTLE BIT HEAVIER,
I FEEL LIKE YOU'RE
TRYING TO TRICK ME.
JASON: AND HEAR THE WORLD?
CLAIRE: IT PIERCED
THROUGH MY SOUL.
JASON: AND EXPERIENCE
THE WORLD DIFFERENTLY?
IF WE CAN FOOL OUR SENSES.
MAN: I FEEL LIKE
IT'S GETTING BIGGER?
I KNOW IT'S NOT RIGHT.
JASON: WHY CAN'T
WE, FINE-TUNE THEM?
FARAH: (BLEEP), IT'S SO HARD!
JASON: MASTER THEM, CAN
WE EVEN FIND A NEW SENSE?
COULD WE EVEN
UNLEASH SUPER SENSES?
MAN: WHAAAAT?
NO, THAT'S (BLEEP).
JASON: SO GET READY TO HAVE
SOME SENSE KNOCKED INTO YOU.
ON BRAIN GAMES!
[CROWD CHEERS].
♪ [THEME MUSIC PLAYS] ♪
THIS IS TIMES
SQUARE IN NEW YORK CITY,
SENSORY OVERLOAD ON STEROIDS.
DISTRACTIONS LEAP OUT AT
US EVERYWHERE WE WALK,
LOOK, OR LISTEN.
IT'S PRETTY MUCH A
MIRACLE THAT OUR BRAINS
DON'T GET OVERWHELMED AND
JUST SHUT DOWN COMPLETELY.
BUT IF YOU HAD TO RELY ON
ONLY THE FIVE BASIC SENSES
IN A PLACE LIKE THIS, YOU
WOULDN'T LAST A MINUTE.
YOU KNOW YOUR
FIVE BASIC SENSES, RIGHT?
MAN: WANT ME TO NAME THEM?
ALRIGHT, THERE'S TOUCH,
THERE'S SMELLING, THERE'S...
WOMAN: TASTE, SMELL.
WOMAN 2: SIGHT,
UH, SMELL, TASTE.
BOY: TOUCH, TASTE,
SMELL, SIGHT AND HEARING.
JASON: DID YOU
REMEMBER THEM ALL?
SIGHT, TOUCH,
SOUND, TASTE, AND SMELL.
THEY'RE THE FIVE
FUNDAMENTAL WAYS YOUR
BRAIN RECEIVES INFORMATION.
THESE SENSES MAKE UP
YOUR BRAIN'S CONTROL PANEL
TO THE WORLD.
COMBINE THEM, AND
YOU GET SUPER SENSES.
FOR EXAMPLE, COMBINE
ELEMENTS OF YOUR SENSES:
TOUCH, SIGHT AND SOUND,
AND YOU GET BALANCE,
A SUPER SENSE
YOU USE EVERY DAY,
WITHOUT EVEN
THINKING ABOUT IT.
WE TESTED BALANCE
IN OUR GAME EARLIER.
DO YOU REMEMBER YOUR TIME?
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS CHART.
SCIENCE SAYS
THE OLDER YOU ARE,
THE HARDER THIS GAME IS.
DOES YOUR TIME
MATCH UP WITH YOUR AGE?
AND HOW ARE THESE
PREDICTIONS SO ACCURATE?
KNOWING HOW YOUR BRAIN
CHANGES OVER A LIFETIME,
WE CAN OBSERVE HOW YOUR
SENSES INTERACT WITH THE WORLD,
AND PREDICT HOW OLD YOU ARE!
BUT THAT'S JUST THE BEGINNING.
JASON: WE'RE GOING TO DIG
DEEP TO EXPLORE NOT JUST THE
FIVE SENSES YOU KNOW ABOUT,
BUT LOTS OF OTHERS YOU
DIDN'T EVEN REALIZE YOU HAD.
LET'S START WITH A GAME.
QUICK, FIND A SEAT AND STICK
YOUR RIGHT FOOT OUT SLIGHTLY.
START TO TURN IT IN
A CLOCKWISE MOTION.
NOW TAKE YOUR RIGHT INDEX
FINGER AND TRY TO DRAW THE
NUMBER SIX FROM
THE TOP DOWN.
WHOOPS.
WHAT HAPPENED?
DID YOUR FOOT SUDDENLY
STOP OR CHANGE DIRECTION?
NO MATTER HOW HARD YOU TRY,
YOU PROBABLY CAN'T DO IT.
THE REASON IS BECAUSE THE
LEFT HEMISPHERE OF YOUR BRAIN
CONTROLS THE RIGHT
SIDE OF YOUR BODY.
AND YOUR BRAIN'S MOTOR
CORTEX GIVES INSTRUCTIONS TO
ONLY ONE SIDE OF YOUR BODY
AT THE SAME TIME.
GIVE DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS
TO YOUR RIGHT ARM AND
YOUR RIGHT LEG, AND
YOU'LL GET THE WRONG RESULTS.
BUT I WANT TO KNOW: HOW
WE CAN HACK OUR BRAINS AND
USE OUR SENSES TO
DO THE UNEXPECTED?
TO FIND OUT, WE CUSTOMIZED
THIS BIKE WITH A SET OF
DIFFERENTIAL GEARS TO
CONTROL THE HANDLE BARS.
TURN THE
HANDLEBARS TO THE RIGHT,
AND THE BIKE
TURNS TO THE LEFT.
THAT'S NOT SO HARD, RIGHT?
SO, WE TOLD ALL OUR FANS IN
TIMES SQUARE AND OFFERED A
HUNDRED BUCKS TO ANYONE WHO
CAN RIDE THIS BIKE 20 FEET!
WE'LL CHECK IN
WITH THEM LATER.
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT IT WILL
TAKE TO UNLOCK OUR SUPER SENSES,
LET'S START BY TESTING
TWO OF OUR BASIC SENSES
AGAINST EACH
OTHER WITH THIS GAME.
SEE THE TWO DOTS
MOVING ACROSS YOUR SCREEN?
DO THESE DOTS PASS
THROUGH EACH OTHER?
OR DO THEY BOUNCE OFF ONE
ANOTHER AND CHANGE DIRECTION?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
IT'S HARD TO SAY, RIGHT?
WELL, THIS TIME
PLAY CLOSE ATTENTION.
[CLANG]
A-HA!
CLEARLY THE DOTS
BOUNCE OFF EACH OTHER.
WELL THIS IS WHAT'S
CALLED A CROSS-MODAL ILLUSION,
WHERE ONE SENSE AFFECTS
HOW THE OTHER OPERATES;
IN THIS CASE THE
SOUND OF A COLLISION...
[CLANG]
CHANGES HOW YOUR BRAIN
SEES THE DOTS INTERACT.
THIS IS BECAUSE OUR
SONIC INSTINCTS RUN DEEP.
TO SHOW YOU JUST HOW DEEP,
WE'VE SET UP A LISTENING
STATION WHERE UNSUSPECTING
VOLUNTEERS CAN TEST OUT
A NEW BRAND OF HEADPHONES.
HOST: I WOULD LOVE FOR
YOU TO GIVE ME YOUR HONEST
OPINION ABOUT OUR
NEW HEADPHONES.
WOULD YOU LIKE
TO TRY THEM OUT?
MAN: BRING IT, LET'S GO.
HOST: TRY THIS ONE ON.
THROW THEM ON.
CHECK IT OUT.
PICK IT UP.
VOLUNTEER: IT'S SO CLEAR.
HOST: EXCELLENT.
VOLUNTEER: OH, I'LL BE JAMMING
ON THE SUBWAY WITH THESE!
HOST: DO IT GIRL, DO IT!
NICE!
JASON: AT FIRST, OUR
VOLUNTEERS ARE PICKING UP
NOTHING BUT GOOD VIBRATIONS.
MAN: LOVE THIS SONG!
YOUNG MAN: BUM, BUM, BUM
AND WHEN YOU TWERK YOU GO,
"BONG BONG BONG BONG."
WOMAN: YEAH, I CAN'T TWERK.
JASON: WHAT THEY DON'T
REALIZE IS WE ARE CONTROLLING
WHAT THEY HEAR
FROM BEHIND THE SET.
BUT WHAT DO YOU THINK
WILL HAPPEN IF WE MIX IN SOME
UNSAVORY SOUNDS, OFFERING UP
A SELECTION OF NOISES RANGING
FROM THE MERELY
OBNOXIOUS TO,
"GET ME THE HECK OUT OF HERE!"
[SCREECHING]
WOMAN: THE NAILS
THAT WERE COMING DOWN.
THAT WAS REALLY WEIRD.
BECAUSE IT WAS LIKE
THE BACK OF MY MOUTH.
THE TEETH WERE LIKE...
[SQUEAK]
WOMAN: NOW IT'S
LIKE A BALLOON.
MAN: OK, MM-HMM.
WOMAN: YOU LOVE THAT ONE,
IS IT SPICE GIRLS?
CLAIRE: IT PIERCED
THROUGH MY SOUL.
CHRIS: OHHHHHHH!!!
CHRIS: THE STYROFOAM STARTS
IN MY BACK AND IT WORKS
ITS WAY UP LIKE THIS, AND
THEN IT COMES UP HERE AND
THEN IT'S IN MY HEAD.
OH, I HATE IT.
[DRY HEAVING]
SAKINA: YEAH, I
DON'T LIKE THAT SOUND!
WOMAN: WHAT'S THAT?
SAKINA: IT SOUNDS LIKE SOME...
[WRETCHES].
SORRY, SOMEBODY'S THROWIN' UP!
WHEN I HEARD THE BARF,
I FELT IT IN MY BODY, LIKE
RIGHT HERE IN MY STOMACH.
THAT MADE ME NAUSEOUS.
JASON: SO WHAT'S
GOING ON HERE?
WHY DO WE HAVE SUCH A
PHYSICAL REACTION TO NOTHING
MORE THAN UNPLEASANT NOISE?
HOW DOES YOUR
BRAIN "SENSE" SOUND?
AND WHY DOES IT RESPOND SO
PHYSICALLY TO SOME SOUNDS,
BUT NOT TO OTHERS?
MEASURED IN
SOMETHING CALLED "HERTZ,"
SOUND WAVES MOVE
THROUGH THE AIR AS VIBRATIONS.
THE HIGHER THE FREQUENCY, THE
MORE POWERFUL THE VIBRATIONS.
THE HIGHLY SENSITIVE SYSTEMS
OF YOUR INNER EAR RECEIVE
THESE SOUND WAVES AND
SEND INFORMATION ABOUT THEM
TO YOUR BRAIN.
REMARKABLY, MANY SOUNDS
TRIGGER YOUR AMYGDALA,
THE PART OF YOUR BRAIN THAT
CONTROLS THE "FIGHT OR FLIGHT"
RESPONSE, SUGGESTING OUR
BRAINS HAVE ACTUALLY EVOLVED
TO ASSOCIATE SOUNDS
OF A CERTAIN FREQUENCY,
WITH DANGER OR DISTRESS.
[HORNS HONKING]
JASON: THESE SOUNDS
AREN'T LANGUAGE,
BUT THEY DO COMMUNICATE.
THEY ARE MEANT TO TRIGGER AN
IMMEDIATE BIOLOGICAL RESPONSE.
SO, THOSE SHIVERS YOU
FEEL ARE PROBABLY TIED TO
OUR ANCIENT
SURVIVAL INSTINCT.
EACH OF YOUR SENSES ON ITS
OWN HAS POWERFUL CONNECTIONS
TO YOUR BRAIN, BUT COMBINED,
YOUR SENSES ARE MORE
POWERFUL THAN YOU MIGHT EXPECT.
MAN: OHHH.
JASON: BRAIN GAMES HAS SET
NEW YORK CITY ON A SUPER SENSE
COLLISION COURSE.
WE'VE OFFERED $100 TO ANY OF
OUR FANS IN TIMES SQUARE WHO
CAN CONQUER THIS
BACKWARDS BIKE.
JASON: HOW'S YOUR DAY GOING?
CHRIS: SO FAR, SO GOOD.
JASON: HOW OLD ARE YOU?
JABEZ: I'M ELEVEN.
JASON: YOU'RE GONNA BE
RIDING THIS BIKE ABOUT
20 FEET THAT WAY.
IF YOU CAN GET
TO THE OTHER END,
THERE'S A $100 BILL,
NICE AND CRISP THERE,
WAITING FOR YOU.
SERGIO: AND I GET TO KEEP IT?
JASON: YOU GET TO KEEP IT!
WHAT DO YOU DO FOR A LIVING?
JERRY: I'M ACTUALLY
A BIKE COURIER.
JASON: FANTASTIC,
WELL, LISTEN.
THIS MIGHT RESPOND
DIFFERENTLY THAN MOST BIKES,
BUT IT IS MECHANICALLY
POSSIBLE TO RIDE IT.
BUT YOU CAN'T, YOUR FEET
CAN'T TOUCH THE FLOOR.
YOU'VE GOT TO ACTUALLY
RIDE THE BIKE THE WHOLE WAY.
THINK YOU'RE UP
FOR THE CHALLENGE?
CHRIS: I THINK SO.
JASON: ARE YOU READY?
FARAH: OH MY GOD YEAH!
I'M TOTALLY READY.
JASON: LET'S DO THIS!
FARAH: AH!
JASON: HERE YOU GO!
READY?
JABEZ: YES.
JASON: LET'S DO THIS!
JABEZ: WHOA!
JASON: I THINK YOU'VE
GOT TO START AGAIN.
JERRY: REALLY HARD!
JASON: ALRIGHT, GO FOR IT.
[LAUGHTER].
GUY: THIS DOES NOT WORK.
(BLEEP)!
JASON: WHY ISN'T RIDING
THIS BIKE AS EASY AS WELL,
RIDING A BIKE?
EVEN IF YOU KNOW THAT TO
RIDE THE BACKWARDS BIKE YOU
MUST STEER RIGHT TO GO LEFT,
AND LEFT TO GO RIGHT,
IN THE MOMENT YOUR BRAIN
CAN'T HELP BUT REACT WRONG.
LET'S LOOK AT THE ROOT
OF THIS BRAIN FAIL STARTING
WITH A GAME.
TAKE YOUR THUMB AND POINTER
FINGER ON THE HAND YOU USE TO
WRITE WITH, HOLDING THEM ABOUT
A QUARTER OF AN INCH APART,
AS IF YOU WERE GRASPING
A SMALL SCREW OR TACK.
NOW, WITHOUT LOOKING,
GENTLY TOUCH THE NAILS OF
THOSE FINGERS TO THE
TIP OF THE INDEX FINGER ON
YOUR OTHER HAND.
HOW MANY DISTINCT POINTS
OF CONTACT CAN YOU FEEL
ON YOUR FINGER?
DID YOU SAY 2?
NOW, AGAIN WITHOUT LOOKING,
GENTLY TOUCH THOSE FINGERS TO
THE MIDDLE OF THE
OPPOSITE FOREARM.
WHAT DO YOU FEEL NOW?
CAN YOU STILL
DISTINGUISH BOTH FINGERS?
PROBABLY NOT.
THAT'S BECAUSE THERE ARE
FAR FEWER NERVE ENDINGS
NEAR THE SURFACE OF THE
SKIN ON YOUR FOREARM.
THE HIGH CONCENTRATION
OF NERVE ENDINGS IN YOUR
FINGERTIPS SEND TONS
OF DETAILED INFORMATION
TO YOUR BRAIN.
TO SEE JUST HOW
SENSITIVE YOUR SENSES CAN BE,
STANFORD UNIVERSITY'S
DR. ALLISON OKAMURA HAS MET
US IN CENTRAL PARK
TO PLAY A GAME.
DR. OKAMURA: OUR EXPERIENCE OF
OUR OWN BODIES INCLUDES
A LOT OF DIFFERENT SENSES,
LIKE PRESSURE AND TOUCH.
JASON: SHE'S GOT A LOW-TECH
BRAIN HACK DESIGNED TO STIMULATE
YOUR SENSES
AND FOOL YOUR BRAIN.
WITH JUST A CHAIR,
A BLINDFOLD,
AND A RELAXING MASSAGE,
CAN DR. OKAMURA MAKE PEOPLE
QUESTION HOW THEY
"SEE" THEIR OWN BODIES?
DR. OKAMURA:
LET'S GIVE IT A TRY.
I'LL LET YOU PUT THIS ON,
COVER YOUR EYES.
JASON: TO GIVE YOU A SENSE
OF WHAT OUR VOLUNTEERS ARE
ABOUT TO EXPERIENCE,
LET'S PLAY A GAME.
CROSS YOUR INDEX
AND MIDDLE FINGER.
NOW TOUCH THE TIP OR
BRIDGE OF YOUR NOSE WITH THE
SPACE WHERE
YOUR FINGERS CROSS.
DOES IT FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE TOUCHING TWO NOSES?
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT IS
CALLED PERCEPTUAL DISJUNCTION.
YOUR BRAIN DOESN'T EXPECT
YOUR FINGERS TO BE CROSSED,
AND SINCE IT'S RARE FOR THE
OUTSIDE OF BOTH FINGERS TO BE
TOUCHING SOMETHING, YOUR
BRAIN FEELS TWO SEPARATE NOSES.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, IT WAS
THE ANCIENT GREEK PHILOSOPHER
ARISTOTLE WHO IS SAID
TO HAVE DISCOVERED THIS
LITTLE BRAIN GAME.
AND MORE THAN
2,000 YEARS LATER,
BRAIN HACKS LIKE THIS
ARE STILL GOING STRONG.
ONCE THESE
VOLUNTEERS ARE BLINDFOLDED,
DR. OKAMURA STIMULATES
NERVES IN THEIR ARMS,
WHICH REMARKABLY TRIGGERS
CONFUSION IN THEIR BRAINS.
DR. OKAMURA:
THINK ABOUT YOUR NOSE,
DOES IT FEEL LIKE
IT ALWAYS DOES?
JESSE: IT FEELS LIKE MY
NOSE IS GETTING BIGGER.
DR. OKAMURA: OK.
JESSE: I CAN'T HOLD
ONTO MY NOSE ANYMORE.
JASON: WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN OUR VOLUNTEERS' BRAINS?
JESSE: SO I HAD A MENTAL
PICTURE OF ALMOST STANDING
OUTSIDE MY BODY,
WATCHING MY NOSE GROW
AND I TRIED TO KEEP MY
HANDS ON MY NOSE,
BUT I COULDN'T
KEEP IT STEADY,
IT JUST KEPT
ON COMING APART.
DR. OKAMURA:
HOW ABOUT NOW?
ANYTHING?
LITTLE GIRL: IT FEELS BIGGER.
LIKE, LONGER.
TOM: MY NOSE IS
GETTING SKINNY.
KIND OF LONG AND SKINNY.
I'M PINOCCHIO!
DR. OKAMURA: RIGHT!
JASON: SO, WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE?
WELL, YOU DON'T NORMALLY
HAVE TO KEEP TOUCHING YOUR
NOSE TO KNOW
WHERE IT IS, RIGHT?
THAT'S BECAUSE THE
NERVE ENDINGS IN YOUR SKIN
GIVE YOU A MENTAL MODEL OF
YOUR BODY'S SHAPE AND SIZE.
STIMULATE YOUR
NERVES UNEXPECTEDLY,
AND YOUR BRAIN'S SENSORY
SIGNALS GET SCRAMBLED.
[HEAVY BREATHING].
NICO: OH MY GOSH!
DR. OKAMURA:
WHAT DO YOU FEEL?
NICO: OH MY GOD.
I THINK IT'S GETTING BIGGER,
BUT I KNOW THIS IS NOT RIGHT!
DR. OKAMURA: NOW I'M GOING
TO USE THIS VIBRATION AND
TOUCH UNDERNEATH YOUR ARM.
JASON: STIMULATE AN
OPPOSITIONAL SET OF NERVES,
AND EVEN MORE
SURPRISING THINGS HAPPEN.
[HEAVY BREATHING, LAUGHTER].
NICO: WHOA, MY GOSH.
DR. OKAMURA: DO YOU FEEL
ANYTHING DIFFERENT NOW?
NICO: UH, YEAH, IT
FEELS LIKE MY NOSE IS
KIND OF GETTING SMALLER?
THAT'S NOT POSSIBLE, IS IT?
DR. OKAMURA: MAYBE YOUR
BRAIN IS TELLING YOU SOMETHING.
NICO: I'M STILL
A BIT CONFUSED.
A LITTLE FREAKED OUT.
JASON: MORE THAN JUST
YOUR SENSE OF TOUCH.
THIS IS PROPRIOCEPTION,
SOMETIMES DESCRIBED
AS, "HOW WE FEEL,"
SENSING YOUR BODY'S
POSITION DURING MOVEMENT.
DR. OKAMURA: THESE NEW
SENSATIONS CAN CAUSE US TO
FEEL SOMETHING DIFFERENT
ABOUT OUR OWN BODY SHAPE.
DR. OKAMURA: WHAT MENTAL
PICTURE IS YOUR BRAIN FORMING
OF YOUR BODY RIGHT NOW?
TOM: WITH THIS ONE?
A LITTLE PIGGISH!
DR. OKAMURA: PIGGISH!
YOUR NOSE IS
GETTING SQUASHED, HUH?
TOM: OINK OINK!
JESSE: WOW!
THAT WAS WEIRD!
DR. OKAMURA: RIGHT!
CATARINA: IT'S SURPRISING
THAT THE BRAIN CAN BE TRICKY
WITH YOUR BODY.
DR. OKAMURA: OK, THANK YOU!
CATARINA: THANK YOU.
DR. OKAMURA: ALRIGHT, YOU
CAN TAKE OFF YOUR BLINDFOLD!
CATARINA: THAT'S SO WEIRD.
CATARINA: AMAZING, AMAZING.
JASON: BLINDFOLDED, IT'S
EASY TO SEE HOW PROPRIOCEPTION
IS A SUPER SENSE YOUR BRAIN
MIGHT TAKE FOR GRANTED.
BUT EVEN WITH YOUR EYES WIDE
OPEN YOU MIGHT BE SURPRISED AT
HOW YOUR SENSES CAN BE FOOLED.
LET'S PLAY A GAME TO
SHOW YOU WHAT I MEAN.
WHICH OF YOUR FIVE BASIC
SENSES IS MOST DIRECTLY LINKED
TO YOUR APPETITE?
THE SENSE OF SMELL
IS A COMMON ANSWER.
WELL, IMAGINE YOU'RE HUNGRY.
WHICH OF THESE TWO
PLATES DO YOU THINK YOU'D
CHOOSE FOR A MEAL,
THIS ONE OR THIS ONE?
MOST PEOPLE SAY
THE ONE ON THE RIGHT.
BECAUSE OF THE
SMALLER PLATE SIZE,
YOUR BRAIN MISJUDGES THE
AMOUNT OF FOOD TO BE GREATER,
WHEN IN FACT IT'S THE
SAME AMOUNT ON BOTH PLATES.
THIS VISUAL MISPERCEPTION
OF RELATIVE SIZES IS CALLED A
DELBOEUF ILLUSION, BUT YOU
CAN TURN IT TO YOUR ADVANTAGE.
SWITCHING FROM A 12-INCH
PLATE TO A 10-INCH PLATE
CAN CAUSE YOU TO
CONSUME 22% LESS FOOD.
YOU'LL WASTE LESS TOO
AND YOU'LL EVEN FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE EATING MORE.
WHEN IT COMES TO APPETITE,
SEEING THE FOOD ON YOUR PLATE
IS AS IMPORTANT AS
TASTING OR SMELLING IT.
BUT HOW DOES YOUR SENSE OF
SIGHT MEASURE UP TO TOUCH?
TO FIND OUT WE'VE
INVITED DR. OKAMURA TO
PLAY ANOTHER GAME WITH
US IN LONG ISLAND CITY.
TAKE A LOOK AT
THESE TWO BOXES.
WE'VE PLACED
WEIGHTS INSIDE THEM BOTH.
USING LOGIC AND EXPERIENCE,
YOUR BRAIN MIGHT THINK THE
BIGGER BOX WEIGHS MORE.
RIGHT?
NOW AS YOU CAN SEE
YOU HAVE THESE TWO BLUE BOXES
IN FRONT OF YOU GUYS.
I WANT YOU TO EVALUATE THEM,
JUST KIND OF WALK AROUND AND
GET A SENSE OF
THEIR DIMENSIONS.
STUDY THEM.
ALAIN: SOME BOXES.
COOL.
JASON: NOW ON MY CUE, I'M
GOING TO HAVE YOU LIFT UP THE
BOX IN FRONT OF YOU, AND
JUST GET A SENSE OF ITS WEIGHT.
ALRIGHT, READY?
GO.
ART: OH MAN!
THAT'S HEAVIER THAN I THOUGHT.
EMMA: THIS IS LIGHTER!
I THINK THIS IS LIGHTER.
JASON: SWAP POSITIONS.
FERNANDO:
ALRIGHT, LET'S DO THIS.
JASON: WHEN I SAY
GO, THE SAME THING.
GO.
[ALAIN GRUNTS].
JASON: OUR VOLUNTEERS
CAN'T PEEK INSIDE.
BUT WHICH ONE WAS
HEAVIER TO YOU?
SHIRA: THIS ONE FEELS
A LITTLE BIT HEAVIER.
JASON: BUT THEY'RE ALLOWED
TO LIFT EACH OF THE BOXES.
ALAN: THAT ONE.
JASON: OKAY.
BOTH AGREE?
ALAN: YES, YES.
JASON: DO YOU BOTH AGREE THAT
THE SMALL ONE SEEMS HEAVIER?
ART: OH YEAH.
JONATHAN: CERTAIN,
ABSOLUTELY CERTAIN.
JASON: EVERYONE
SEEMS TO AGREE THE
SMALLER BOX WEIGHS MORE.
TYLER: I FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE TRYING TO TRICK ME!
JASON: WE'VE PLACED WEIGHTS
INSIDE OF EACH OF THESE BOXES.
WE ASKED OUR VOLUNTEERS
WITHOUT PEEKING TO TELL US
WHICH IS HEAVIER.
MAN: THAT ONE
SEEMED HEAVIER.
MAN 2: DEFINITELY,
YEAH, DEFINITELY.
BOY: UH, THIS IS LIGHTER.
WOMAN: YEAH, THIS ONE
FEELS A LITTLE BIT HEAVIER,
WHICH I THOUGHT
IT WOULD BE LIGHTER,
BUT IT'S NOT, I THINK.
HM, LET ME DO IT ONE MORE.
HUH, OKAY.
JASON: SO WHEN YOU
JUST LOOKED AT THE BOXES,
WHEN YOU JUST
LOOKED AT THE SIZE,
WHICH ONE DID YOU
THINK WOULD BE HEAVIER?
ALAIN: UM, I GUESS THIS ONE,
BECAUSE IT WAS
JUST SO BIG, SO.
JASON: WELL IT'S BIGGER, SO.
ALAIN: INITIALLY YOU'RE GOING
TO THINK BIGGER MEANS HEAVIER.
FERNANDO: YEAH, I WAS
THINKING THE SAME THING TOO.
JASON: TURNS OUT THIS GAME
REQUIRES MORE THAN JUST YOUR
SENSE OF SIGHT AND TOUCH.
YOUR BRAIN ALSO
RELIES ON "MOTOR LEARNING,
A KIND OF MUSCLE
MEMORY SUPER SENSE,
TO GAUGE THE
WEIGHT OF THE BOXES.
SO, WHICH BOX IS
REALLY HEAVIER?
JASON: BRING
THAT ONE OVER HERE,
AND THEN READ THE READING
FROM THE SCALE IN POUNDS.
ALAIN: OK, 14 POUNDS.
JASON: 14 POUNDS, ALRIGHT.
SO NOW WE KNOW THE
"LIGHTER" BOX IS 14 POUNDS.
LET'S BRING IN
THE "HEAVIER" BOX.
ALAIN: "HEAVIER BOX."
FERNANDO: ALRIGHT, 14 POUNDS.
[LAUGHTER]
SHIRA: WAIT, WHAT?
JASON: WHAT DOES IT SAY?
SHIRA: 14 POUNDS.
EMMA: 14 POUNDS,
IT'S THE SAME EXACT THING!
BUT, WAIT, WAIT, REALLY?
JASON: YEAH!
EMMA: HOW DOES THAT EVEN
WORK, THOUGH, LIKE, WHY?
DR. OKAMURA: WELL, WHEN
YOU FIRST PICK UP THE BOX,
YOU HAVE THIS EXPECTATION
THAT THE LARGER ONE WILL BE
HEAVIER, AND SO YOU APPLY
MORE FORCE THAN YOU NEED,
AND THAT MAKES IT WIND UP
FEELING LIGHTER IN A WAY.
DR. OKAMURA: BUT YOU
LIFTED IT MULTIPLE TIMES AND
YOU MOVED IT AROUND,
AND YOU REALLY DEVELOPED
AN INTERNAL MODEL OF
WHAT THE WEIGHT WAS.
IN OTHER WORDS YOUR MOTOR
SENSING SYSTEM FIGURED IT OUT.
IT KNOWS THAT IT REQUIRES THE
SAME FORCE TO LIFT EACH BOX.
BUT, THE COGNITIVE,
PERCEPTUAL PART OF YOUR BRAIN
REFUSES TO ACCEPT
THAT CONCLUSION.
SO IT STILL THINKS THAT
THE SMALLER BOX IS HEAVIER.
JASON: WHAT DOES THAT
TELL YOU ABOUT YOUR BRAIN?
EMMA: IT HAS LIED TO ME.
I DO NOT TRUST
ANYTHING, ANYMORE, EVER.
JASON: WE LIVE IN THE MATRIX.
EMMA: OH GOD, NO, WHOO.
JASON: BUT THERE WAS ONE
RESULT I WANT TO LOOK AT AGAIN:
WHEN TWO WEIGHTLIFTERS
TRIED THE EXPERIMENT,
THEY HAD A DIFFERENT
REACTION THAN MOST.
RAYMOND: HOW WAS YOURS?
COMPARE IT TO A PLATE.
TYLER: I FEEL
LIKE THEY'RE CLOSE.
JASON: BUT WHICH ONE
WAS HEAVIER TO YOU?
RAYMOND: I THINK, I THINK,
THEY'RE THE SAME.
TYLER: YEAH.
RAYMOND: AT LEAST TO
ME THEY FELT THE SAME.
JASON: THEY FELT THE SAME?
THEIR EXTRA EXPERIENCE
LIFTING WEIGHTS HELPED THEM
SENSE THE BOXES
WEIGHED EXACTLY THE SAME.
AS THE SAYING GOES,
PRACTICE MAKES PERFECT.
IS THAT WHY PEOPLE IN
TIMES SQUARE ARE HAVING SUCH
A HARD TIME WITH
OUR BACKWARDS BIKE?
[GRUNTS, COMMOTION].
FARAH: (BLEEP), IT'S SO HARD!
JASON: ALRIGHT, GO DIEGO.
MAN: THIS IS NOT WORKING.
[CROWD CHEERS].
JASON: TO HELP EXPLAIN
OUR PEDAL-POWERED PROBLEM
WE TURNED TO DR. ANDY MURRAY,
A NEUROSCIENTIST FROM
COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY.
SO WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THE BRAIN,
WHY ARE PEOPLE GETTING
SO TRIPPED UP TRYING TO
RIDE THIS BIKE?
DR. MURRAY: IF YOU WANT TO
UNDERSTAND NEURAL NETWORKS,
AND WHY IT'S SO DIFFICULT TO
CHANGE A LEARNED MOTOR SKILL,
YOU COULD THINK OF A RIVERBED.
SO INITIALLY WATER FLOWS
IN A COMPLETELY RANDOM WAY,
AND THEN EVENTUALLY IT
STARTS TO FORM A PATH IN THE
SAND AND THE STONES.
AND WATER THAT COMES
AFTER THIS WILL FLOW MUCH
SMOOTHER AND FASTER.
DR. MURRAY: AND
IN THE SAME WAY,
WHEN YOU LEARN A
NEW MOTOR SKILL,
THE FLOW OF INFORMATION
THROUGH YOUR BRAIN IS
INITIALLY RATHER
RANDOM AND CONVOLUTED.
JASON: SURE.
DR. MURRAY: BUT WHEN YOU
REPEAT THAT SKILL OVER AND
OVER AGAIN, THE PATHWAYS
BECOME STRENGTHENED,
AND THE INFORMATION
FLOWS THROUGH THE BRAIN MUCH
FASTER AND SMOOTHER.
JASON: LET'S SEE IF
YOUR BRAIN CAN DEAL WITH
A LITTLE RANDOMNESS.
TAKE THE RANDOM WORDS
WE PUT UP ON SCREEN.
AND MAKE IT INTO A
SENTENCE THAT MAKES SENSE.
GIVE IT A TRY.
DID YOU GET, "TIMES
SQUARE IS VERY BUSY?"
GO AHEAD AND TRY IT AGAIN.
THIS ONE READS,
"LET THE GOOD TIMES ROLL."
NOW FOR ROUND THREE.
THIS TIME YOU
PROBABLY FIGURED OUT,
"LEMON IS THE SOUREST FRUIT."
WAS THIS LAST SENTENCE
EASIER TO UNSCRAMBLE
THAN THE FIRST TWO?
DOING A TASK ONCE AND
LEARNING BASIC DIRECTIONS,
YOUR BRAIN BEGINS TO
CARVE A PATH FOR THIS TASK.
SO, PERHAPS THE BRAIN
BEST-SUITED TO CONQUER OUR
BACKWARDS BIKE WILL BELONG
TO SOMEONE WHO HAS SPENT
YEARS DEDICATED
TO RIDING A BIKE.
JASON: CHARLES.
CHARLES: JASON.
JASON: WELCOME TO BRAIN GAMES.
CHARLES: THANK YOU,
HAPPY TO BE HERE.
JASON: NEUROSCIENTIST
DR. ANDY MURRAY.
CHARLES: NICE TO
MEET YOU, PLEASURE.
JASON: SO, YOU'RE A
PROFESSIONAL BMX RIDER, RIGHT?
CHARLES: RIGHT, I'VE
CYCLED FOR ABOUT 20, 25 YEARS.
JASON: OK.
CHARLES: I RIDE FREESTYLE
BMX, I RIDE FIXED GEAR.
AS A COMMUTER IN THE CITY,
YOU KNOW I DEFINITELY
WAS UP FOR THE CHALLENGE.
JASON: MASTERING THE
BACKWARDS BIKE WON'T BE EASY
EVEN FOR A
PROFESSIONAL BIKE RIDER.
SO, WE GAVE CHARLES THE
BACKWARDS BIKE FOR TWO WEEKS
TO SEE IF HE COULD
REWIRE HIS MOTOR MEMORY WITH
A LITTLE EXTRA TIME.
AND SPEAKING OF TIME,
LET'S PLAY A GAME THAT MIGHT
TURN BACK THE CLOCK USING
ONE OF YOUR SENSES.
LOOK AT THESE IMAGES OF FIVE
POPULAR AND COMMON SCENTS:
CINNAMON, ORANGE, PINE TREE,
PEPPERMINT AND LIME.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE THEM AWAY AND LAY THEM
FACE DOWN IN
THE ORIGINAL ORDER.
CAN YOU REMEMBER FROM
JUST A FEW SECONDS AGO WHAT
THE ORIGINAL ORDER WAS?
DID YOU GET IT RIGHT?
WERE YOU ABLE TO
RECALL CINNAMON,
ORANGE, PINE TREE,
PEPPERMINT, THEN LIME?
DID YOU EVEN START TO
SMELL THE SCENT OF THE IMAGES
WE SHOWED YOU?
THIS IS BECAUSE, UNLIKE
TOUCH, SIGHT AND HEARING,
YOUR SENSE OF SMELL HAS
SOME UNIQUE ABILITIES.
YOUR NOSE'S OLFACTORY
BULB IS ACTUALLY PART OF
THE LIMBIC SYSTEM,
WITH INTIMATE ACCESS TO
YOUR HIPPOCAMPUS AND AMYGDALA,
THE PARTS OF YOUR BRAIN MOST
LINKED TO MEMORY AND EMOTION.
YOU MIGHT SAY THE MEMORY OF
THOSE SCENTS TOOK YOU ON A
KIND OF TIME TRAVEL,
RECALLING A WHIFF OF CINNAMON
OR FRESH PINE
EXPERIENCED LONG AGO.
AND HELPING YOU REMEMBER
THE ORDER OF THE CARDS
WE SHOWED YOU.
THIS IS ONE WAY SENSES
AFFECT OUR IDEA OF TIME,
A SUPER SENSE ALL ITS OWN.
AND FOR OUR NEXT GAME,
WE'RE BACK IN TIMES SQUARE
WITH MENTALIST MARC SALEM
TO SEE IF HE CAN
STOP TIME ALL TOGETHER.
MARC: DID IT STOP
WORKING COMPLETELY?
MAN: IT DID.
JASON: QUICK, PAY ATTENTION.
I'M ABOUT TO SHOW YOU A
MAGIC SQUARE WHERE THE NUMBERS
1 THROUGH 9 ARE
ARRANGED SO THAT EVERY ROW
AND EVERY COLUMN,
EVEN THE DIAGONALS
ADD UP TO 15.
BUT THIS IS BRAIN GAMES
SO THERE'S A TWIST.
SOME NUMBERS WILL BE MISSING.
YOU MUST FILL IN
THOSE MISSING NUMBERS.
AND TRY TO KEEP TRACK
OF HOW LONG WE GIVE YOU TO
SOLVE THIS MAGIC SQUARE.
ARE YOU READY?
HERE WE GO.
♪ ♪
OKAY, TIME'S UP.
THINK YOU HAVE THE ANSWER?
DID YOU PLACE THE NUMBERS
4, 7, AND 1 IN THESE SPOTS?
IF SO, GOOD WORK.
BUT HOW LONG DO YOU
THINK WE GAVE YOU TO
SOLVE THIS PUZZLE?
FIVE SECONDS, TEN?
ACTUALLY WE GAVE
YOU A FULL 15 SECONDS,
BUT IT FELT LIKE
A LOT LESS, RIGHT?
THIS IS BECAUSE MENTALLY
STIMULATING OR CHALLENGING
TASKS ACTUALLY MAKE
TIME SEEM TO PASS FASTER.
AND HERE'S ANOTHER GAME
THAT RELIES ON YOUR ABILITY
TO ESTIMATE THE
PASSAGE OF TIME.
PAY ATTENTION TO
THIS SHORT VIDEO CLIP.
[FAST TEMPO MUSIC PLAYS]
HOW LONG WOULD YOU
SAY THAT CLIP LASTED?
THE ANSWER: EIGHT SECONDS.
NOW, WATCH THIS CLIP.
[SLOW TEMPO MUSIC PLAYS]
SO WHICH CLIP WAS LONGER?
THE TWO VIDEOS WERE
ACTUALLY THE SAME LENGTH.
HOW COULD THAT BE?
THE MORE COMPLEX SEQUENCE
OF EVENTS SHOULD TRIGGER
HEIGHTENED NEURAL ACTIVITY
IN PARTS OF YOUR BRAIN
THAT HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO
DILATE YOUR SENSE OF TIME.
THAT'S WHY FOR MOST
PEOPLE THE FIRST CLIP SEEMS
LONGER THAN THE SECOND ONE.
BUT IS IT POSSIBLE
TO STOP TIME ENTIRELY?
USING HIS MASTER
MENTALIST SKILLS,
MARC SALEM IS TRYING TO
STOP AND EVEN CHANGE HOW
THESE PEOPLE SENSE TIME.
MARC: IT'S 11:30,
IS IT WORKING?
VOLUNTEER: NO, IT STOPPED.
MARC: IS IT AN
EXPENSIVE WATCH?
VOLUNTEER: YEAH, VERY.
MARC: WELL, THEN IT'S
TIME TO GET IT FIXED.
MAN: IT'S, IT'S
ALMOST LIKE 1:00.
YOU LIKED JUMPED IT LIKE.
MARC: NO, I DIDN'T JUMP IT,
YOU MOVED THROUGH TIME.
NOW IS IT WORKING?
VOLUNTEER: YEAH.
MARC: YEAH AND WHAT TIME
DOES A CORRECT WATCH SAY?
ARE THERE ANY
CORRECT WATCHES?
BYSTANDER: 11:32.
MARC: 11:32, AND YOURS SAYS?
WOMAN: 11:36.
MARC: 11:36.
WOMAN: I'M IN THE FUTURE.
MARC: SO YOU'RE
ALREADY IN THE FUTURE.
JASON: MARC'S ABILITY TO
STOP TIME RELIES ON HIS
UNDERSTANDING OF THE MANY
MINUTE WAYS THAT PEOPLE SENSE
AND INTERACT WITH THE WORLD,
ALLOWING HIM TO LEAD OUR
SENSES TO EXPERIENCE
ONLY WHAT HE WANTS US TO.
IT'S A TALENT THAT
MARC HAS PERFECTED WITH
YEARS OF PRACTICE.
WHILE ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF TIMES SQUARE,
CHARLES HAS BEEN PRACTICING
WITH OUR ULTIMATE TEST OF
SUPER-SENSORY SKILL, THE
BRAIN GAMES BACKWARDS BIKE.
TELL US, WHAT HAVE YOU
BEEN DOING WITH THIS BIKE?
CHARLES: THE FIRST TIME
I GOT ON IT I WASN'T ABLE
TO GO A FOOT.
I COULDN'T GET MY
FEET TO THE PEDALS.
STEERING WAS VERY
COUNTER-INTUITIVE.
IT WAS SORT OF LIKE
BEING A 5-YEAR-OLD AGAIN.
DR. MURRAY: YOUR BRAIN
AUTOMATICALLY WANTS TO USE
THIS PATHWAY THAT
IT'S PREVIOUSLY BUILT.
SO NOT ONLY ARE YOU
LEARNING A NEW SKILL,
YOU'RE OVERCOMING
THIS OLD SKILL.
JASON: SO YOU'VE
BEEN PRACTICING.
CHARLES: YES.
JASON: AND DURING THAT
TIME YOU DIDN'T RIDE YOUR
NORMAL BIKE AT ALL, RIGHT?
CHARLES: RIGHT, SO
THERE WAS NO REGULAR STEERING,
ONLY THE REVERSE STEERING.
JASON: YOU READY
TO GIVE IT A SHOT?
CHARLES: YEAH.
JASON: ALRIGHT, LET'S DO THIS.
♪ ♪
[CROWD CHEERS, CLAPS].
HO-HO-HO, HO-HO-HO!
GREAT JOB, CHARLES.
CHARLES: THANK YOU.
JASON: THAT WAS AMAZING.
SO THOSE TWO WEEKS
OF PRACTICE PAID OFF, HUH?
CHARLES: ABSOLUTELY.
IT WAS A LOT OF FUN,
TO BE ABLE TO DO
IT WITH AN AUDIENCE.
JASON: STARTED TO
FEEL NATURAL A LITTLE BIT?
CHARLES: ABSOLUTELY.
JASON: SO DOES THAT
MEAN THAT HE WAS CREATING
A NEW NEURAL PATHWAY, RIGHT?
ANDY MURRAY: YEAH, I
THINK THERE'S DEFINITELY BEEN
SOME REMODELING THERE.
JASON: WITH TWO
WEEKS TO PRACTICE,
CHARLES HAS REPROGRAMMED
THE PART OF HIS BRAIN THAT
LEARNED TO RIDE A NORMAL
BIKE ALL THOSE YEARS AGO.
BUT THE EXPERIMENT
ISN'T QUITE OVER.
OK, SO YOU'VE BEEN
PRACTICING ON THE INVERTED
ONE FOR TWO WEEKS,
AND YOU HAVEN'T TOUCHED
THE ORIGINAL BIKE.
CHARLES: I HAVEN'T BEEN ON
MY OLD BMX BIKE IN TWO WEEKS.
JASON: ALRIGHT, WELL,
WE HAVE A SURPRISE FOR YOU
HERE ON BRAIN GAMES.
WE'RE BRINGING YOUR ORIGINAL
BMX BIKE OUT HERE TO SEE IF
YOU CAN STILL RIDE IT.
CHARLES: OH, YIKES.
JASON: YOU GUYS THINK
HE'S GONNA DO THIS?
[CROWD CHEERING].
DR. MURRAY: I THINK THIS IS
GOING TO BE VERY DIFFICULT.
CHARLES: I'M EAGER
TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
♪ ♪
JASON: WE'VE GIVEN ONE
PROFESSIONAL BIKE RIDER THE
CHANCE TO MASTER HIS
SENSES AND DO WHAT OUR BRAINS
TELL US IS IMPOSSIBLE:
RIDE A BACKWARDS BICYCLE.
YOU READY TO GIVE IT A SHOT?
CHARLES: YEAH.
JASON: ALRIGHT, LET'S DO THIS.
[CROWD CHEERS].
HO-HO-HO!
AND, AFTER TWO WEEKS
OF DEDICATED PRACTICE,
CHARLES CONQUERED HIS BRAIN.
GREAT JOB, CHARLES.
CHARLES: THANK YOU.
JASON: THAT WAS AMAZING.
SO THOSE TWO WEEKS
OF PRACTICE PAID OFF, HUH?
CHARLES: ABSOLUTELY.
JASON: BUT WHAT DO YOU
THINK WILL HAPPEN WHEN
CHARLES CLIMBS BACK ON
HIS OWN PERSONAL BIKE?
[CROWD CHEERS].
COME ON CHARLES,
COME ON CHARLES!
WOW.
CHARLES' MOTOR MEMORY FAILS
HIM AFTER ONLY A FEW FEET.
WHAT USED TO BE SO INTUITIVE
HAS NOW BECOME THE OPPOSITE.
WHAT HAPPENED, CHARLES?
CHARLES: I DON'T KNOW.
DR. MURRAY: TOUGH, RIGHT?
JASON: INTERESTING, RIGHT?
IT'S LIKE THOSE 2 WEEKS
CARVED A NEW NEURAL PATHWAY
IN YOUR BRAIN AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN THIS BECAME UNNATURAL.
CHARLES: RIGHT.
DR. MURRAY: SO THIS IS A
REALLY INCREDIBLE EXAMPLE OF
WHAT WE CALL NEUROPLASTICITY.
SO RESEARCHERS HAVE FOUND
THAT YOUR ABILITY TO LEARN AND
RELEARN DIFFERENT MOTOR TASKS
ARE LINKED TO A PARTICULAR
PART OF THE BRAIN
CALLED THE CEREBELLUM.
AND WHAT THIS AREA DOES
IS IT COMPARES WHAT WE ARE
TRYING TO DO WITH WHAT WE'VE
DONE IN OUR PAST.
AND SO IT SLOWLY
UPDATES THE PATHWAYS AS WE
LEARN NEW SKILLS.
SO NOW YOU'RE STUCK
WITH THIS NEW PATHWAY AND
IT'S DIFFICULT
TO RIDE YOUR BIKE.
JASON: HOW DID IT FEEL?
CHARLES: IT FELT STRANGE.
JASON: STRANGE?
CHARLES: RIGHT,
FAMILIAR, BUT STRANGE.
JASON: LIKE
SOMETHING WAS OFF.
CHARLES: DEFINITELY.
JASON: WELL AS IT TURNS OUT
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO QUICKLY
UNLEARN THE NEW SKILL
AND REGAIN BACK YOUR MOJO.
ANDY: COUPLE OF DAYS
EVEN AND YOU'LL BE GREAT.
CHARLES: YEAH, I
THINK I'M GONNA BE TAKING
THE SUBWAY HOME!
JASON: YES,
YOU WILL, ALRIGHT!
WELL THANKS FOR
BEING HERE CHARLES,
YOU WERE AMAZING.
CHARLES: THANKS JASON.
JASON: WE CAN TRICK AND
FINE-TUNE AND TRAIN OUR BRAINS
INTO MENTAL-SENSORY MASTERY.
BUT CAN WE GO BEYOND
OUR FIVE BASIC SENSES?
LET'S PLAY A GAME
IN THREE ROUNDS.
TAKE A GOOD LOOK AT
THESE RED AND GREEN DOTS.
THEY'RE GOING TO DISAPPEAR
AND WHEN YOU SEE THEM AGAIN,
TELL ME IF YOU THINK
ANY OF THE DOTS CHANGED.
WHAT DID YOU THINK:
CHANGE OR NO CHANGE?
TIME FOR ROUND TWO.
DID YOU SEE ANY
CHANGE THIS TIME?
REMEMBER YOUR ANSWERS.
IT'S TIME FOR OUR FINAL ROUND.
SO WHICH ROUNDS DID YOU
SAY HAD CHANGING DOTS?
IF YOU SAID ROUNDS 1 AND 3,
YOU'RE RIGHT.
THERE WAS NO
CHANGE IN ROUND 2.
IF WE ASKED YOU WHICH
EXACT DOTS EXACTLY CHANGED,
THAT MIGHT BE TOO MUCH
FOR YOUR BRAIN TO HANDLE.
BUT STUDIES SHOW, MOST
PEOPLE SAY THE IMAGE CHANGES
EVEN THOUGH THEY CAN'T SAY
EXACTLY WHAT HAS CHANGED.
YOU MIGHT SAY THOSE OF
YOU WHO ANSWERED CORRECTLY
SENSED SOMETHING YOU
DIDN'T ACTUALLY SEE.
DOES THAT SOUND
LIKE A SIXTH SENSE?
OUR SUPER SENSEI MASTER MARC,
HAS DEVELOPED HIS SUPER-SENSE
OF MICRO-OBSERVATION,
THE ABILITY TO SENSE
WHAT OTHERS CANNOT,
TO READ MINUTE DETAILS OF
BODY LANGUAGE AND ATTITUDE.
MARC: WHAT IF I TOLD
YOU THAT I COULD GUARANTEE
I COULD TELL WITH VIRTUALLY
100% IF SOMEBODY'S LYING.
JASON: I'D SAY
YOU WERE LYING.
MARC: WHAT IF I SAID LET'S
TEST THIS ON OUR NEXT GAME.
JASON: ALRIGHT.
BY GETTING THESE PEOPLE
TO TELL A LITTLE WHITE LIE,
MARC CAN UNCOVER WHO'S
ACTUALLY TELLING THE TRUTH.
MARC: IN A MOMENT
I'M GOING TO ASK YOU ALL
TO MAKE A DRAWING.
JASON: OK.
MARC: IT CAN BE A SKETCH,
A DOODLE, SOMETHING
YOU'VE DRAWN BEFORE,
SOMETHING YOU'VE
NEVER DRAWN BEFORE.
THE IMPORTANT THING IS THAT
IT BE A DRAWING OF SOMETHING.
JASON: OK.
MARC: YOUR FIFTEEN
SECONDS BEGINS NOW.
YOU SHOULD BE DRAWING
ALREADY, BECAUSE ALREADY.
SEVEN, SIX, COME ON
YOU KNOW THE WORD,
5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
MARKERS ON THE FLOOR.
GREAT, PASS
THEM ALL TO JASON.
THE DRAWINGS.
JASON: THANKS GUYS,
THANK YOU.
MARC: JASON, MIX THEM ALL UP.
JASON: VERY, VERY MIXED UP.
MARC: MIX, MIX,
MIX, MIX, MIX, MIX.
JASON: MAKING THIS INTO
THE MOST RANDOM SHUFFLE
IN THE UNIVERSE.
MARC: ALRIGHT, ALL MIXED UP?
JASON: ALL MIXED UP.
MARC: DRAWINGS TOO?
JASON: DRAWINGS TOO.
MARC: OK, EXCELLENT.
HERE'S WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO,
I'M GOING TO TRY IDENTIFYING
THROUGH BODY LANGUAGE AND
OTHER SORTS OF
TECHNIQUES WHO DREW WHAT.
I'M GOING TO ASK
YOU IF YOU DREW THIS.
SIMPLY SAY NO.
I'M GOING TO SEE IF
I CAN'T PICK UP THOSE
SUBTLETIES THAT SAY
THAT YOU'RE LYING OR
THAT YOU'RE NOT.
DID YOU DRAW THIS?
WOMAN: NO.
MARC: DID YOU DRAW THIS?
JASON: NO.
WOMAN: NO.
MARC: DID YOU DRAW THIS?
MAN: NO.
MARC: OK, I'VE GOTTA SAY.
JASON: BEFORE MARC USES
HIS SUPER SENSES TO TELL
WHO IS LYING,
LOOK AT EACH OF
OUR CONTESTANTS CLOSELY.
IS THERE ANYTHING YOU
NOTICE ABOUT THEIR BEHAVIOR?
WHO DO YOU THINK IS LYING?
LET'S SEE IF YOUR SUPER
SENSES ARE AS GOOD AS MARC'S.
MARC: I SEE OCCUR ON
STAGE EVERY SINGLE NIGHT,
ONE PERSON LOOKS HOW THE
OTHER PEOPLE ARE RESPONDING,
THEY TURN THEIR HEAD.
ONLY ONE PERSON DID THAT.
THAT WAS YOU.
THIS MUST BE YOURS.
IS THAT CORRECT?
JASON: HOLY (BLEEP)!
YEAH, I'M IMPRESSED.
LET'S WATCH THAT AGAIN.
MARC: DID YOU DRAW THIS?
JASON: NO.
THAT'S RIGHT.
MARC CAUGHT MY HEAD SWIVEL
TO WATCH THE OTHER PLAYERS.
DID THAT OCCUR TO YOU?
WHAT OTHER CLUES CAN HE FIND?
NOW THAT YOU'RE MORE
AWARE OF WHAT MICRO CLUES
TO LOOK FOR, TRY AGAIN.
MARC: DID YOU DRAW THIS?
WOMAN: NO.
MAN: NO.
JASON: HOW ABOUT THIS TIME,
CATCH THE TELL?
MARC: THAT'S THE CLINTON, NO.
THAT'S WHERE SOMEBODY
WANTS TO TELL THE TRUTH BUT
THEY'RE NOT SO THEY
DO A LITTLE THIS...
OK AND THAT'S WHAT YOU DID.
[LAUGHTER].
WOMAN: HOW'D YOU KNOW?!
JASON: DID YOU
GET IT THIS TIME?
ACCORDING TO MARC, THIS
SUPER SENSE CAN BE LEARNED BY
ANYONE WHO PAYS ATTENTION.
MARC: THERE'S A MILLION THINGS
GOING ON IN OUR ENVIRONMENT,
SIMULTANEOUSLY, BUT I
THINK PEOPLE ARE WALKING
THROUGH LIFE NOT
SEEING EVERYTHING.
DID YOU DRAW THIS,
DID YOU DRAW THIS?
MAN: NO.
MARC: DID YOU DRAW THIS?
WOMAN: NO.
MARC: YOU SHOULDN'T
STARE SOMEONE IN THE EYES
WHEN YOU'RE LYING.
WHEN WE STARE PEOPLE IN
THE EYES IT MEANS WE'RE
UNCOMFORTABLE AND WE
WANT POWER OVER THEM.
ONE PERSON
LOCKED INTO MY EYES,
DIDN'T CHANGE IT AT
ALL, THAT WAS YOU.
WOMAN: I KNOW
THIS STUFF AND YET,
I STILL COULDN'T
HELP MYSELF.
I STILL COULDN'T HELP
OVERDOING THINGS TO TRY
TO NOT LOOK
LIKE I WAS LYING.
I JUST THINK THAT'S
AN AMAZING SKILL.
I WISH I HAD THAT.
LIKE I REALLY THINK THAT'S
THE COOLEST KIND OF MAGIC.
JASON: NOW THAT
YOU'VE HAD SOME PRACTICE,
LET'S PLAY A GAME TO SEE IF
YOU CAN FIND ANOTHER FAKER.
SEE THESE FOUR SMILING FACES?
ALL OF THEM LOOK HAPPY, RIGHT?
BUT IF YOU HAD TO
GUESS, WHO WAS THE HAPPIEST,
WHO WOULD YOU PICK?
IF YOU SAID THIS SMILE,
YOU'RE RIGHT.
BUT WHAT MAKES ONE
SMILE HAPPIER THAN ANOTHER?
IT TURNS OUT THERE ARE 19
DIFFERENT TYPES OF SMILES,
BUT ONLY ONE IS A TRUE
SMILE OF PURE ENJOYMENT CALLED
THE DUCHENNE SMILE.
THIS SMILE RESULTS FROM
SMALL MUSCLES AROUND THE EYES
THAT CONTRACT WHEN THE
EMOTION OF JOY IS FELT,
INVOLUNTARILY CREATING A
GENUINE SMILE THAT IS ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO FAKE.
OTHER TYPES OF
SMILES EXPRESS OR CONCEAL
ALL KINDS OF EMOTIONS.
SO IF YOU SPOT A SMILE
THAT ISN'T ON THE UP AND UP,
LOOK TO THE EYES.
WATCHING YOUR EYES IS
JUST ONE OF THE WAYS MARC
IS ABLE TO CONDUCT HIS
TIMES SQUARE LIE DETECTOR TEST.
WITH ONLY ONE SKETCH LEFT,
IT'S NOT HARD TO
GUESS WHO DREW IT.
BUT CAN MARC TELL WHAT
THE LAST PERSON DREW,
WITHOUT LOOKING AT HIS CARD?
MAN: THAT'S
WHEN IT GOT CRAZY.
JASON: MENTALIST MARC SALEM
IS ABOUT TO USE THE POWERS
OF HIS SUPER SENSES TO
FEEL THE IMPERCEPTIBLE AND
READ THE MINDS
OF OUR VOLUNTEERS.
MARC: LET ME, UM,
JUST START TO,
RUN THROUGH SOMETHING,
ANIMAL, VEGETABLE, MINERAL,
DO NOT RESPOND.
IS IT AN ANIMAL,
VEGETABLE OR MINERAL.
UH SOME KIND OF
ANIMAL, SOME KIND OF ANIMAL,
BUT IT'S NOT AN ANIMAL,
IT'S AN ANIMAL,
IT'S NOT AN ANIMAL.
IT'S UH PART OF AN ANIMAL.
IT'S PART OF AN ANIMAL
BUT IT'S ALSO A PART OF LUST,
IT'S A PART OF LUSTFUL ANIMAL.
IT'S PART OF LUSTFUL
ANIMAL, WHICH IS YOU.
IT'S A PART OF YOU,
OK, FEELING THAT WAY.
THIS IS FEBRUARY,
THIS IS A VALENTINE.
CAN WE SEE WHAT HE DREW?
MAN: WHAT?!
JASON: IT'S A HEART.
MAN: THAT'S WHEN IT
GOT CRAZY, I WAS LIKE,
WHAT LIKE HE LITERALLY
FIGURED OUT WHAT I DREW AND
UH, JUST BY LOOKING AT ME.
MAN: YO,
THAT'S (BLEEP), WHAT?!
[LAUGHTER].
JASON: WOW, VERY IMPRESSIVE.
WOMAN: THAT'S AWESOME.
MAN: VERY IMPRESSIVE.
JASON: I'M BLOWN AWAY.
MARC: THANKS, GUYS.
MAN: OH, MY GOD.
MARC: THANKS, GUYS, THANKS.
JASON: INCREDIBLY, USING HIS
POWER OF MICRO-OBSERVATION,
A DILATED PUPIL OR
A TWITCHING MUSCLE,
IT'S ALL MARC
NEEDS TO SENSE HEARTS,
A WATERFALL, A SURFER
RIDING A TIDAL WAVE,
EGGS AND BACON,
EVEN AN OCEAN LINER,
WHATEVER'S ON YOUR MIND!
CAN ANYBODY LEARN
HOW TO DO THIS?
MARC: I KNEW YOU WERE
GOING TO ASK ME THAT.
YES.
EVERYBODY ABSOLUTELY
COULD DO THIS.
JASON: BUT SURELY
THERE ARE LIMITS, RIGHT?
LIKE IT'S NOT LIKE WE COULD
STOP A RANDOM PERSON HERE
IN TIMES SQUARE AND
READ THEIR MINDS.
MARC: YEAH OF
COURSE WE COULD,
WE COULD DO THIS RIGHT HERE
IN TIMES SQUARE BUT SOMETHING
OF THIS MAGNITUDE REALLY
DESERVES A BIGGER STAGE.
JASON: MMM!
MARC HAS TAKEN OVER
TIMES SQUARE TO ATTEMPT A
MASSIVE MIND-MELD, AND
PROVE HIS SUPER-SIXTH SENSE
IS THE REAL DEAL!
MARC: WE'RE GOING TO USE
WHAT ARE CALLED ZENER CARDS,
OR SOMETIMES ESP CARDS.
THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT SHAPES.
ONE IS A STAR,
ONE IS A CIRCLE,
ONE IS A SQUARE, WE
HAVE THE WAVY LINES,
AND THE LAST ONE
IS A PLUS SIGN.
JASON: WHAT
ABOUT YOU AT HOME?
TAKE A LOOK AT
THESE FIVE CARDS AGAIN.
A STAR, A CIRCLE, A SQUARE,
WE HAVE THE WAVY LINES,
AND A PLUS SIGN.
MARC: NOW I WANT YOU ALL
TO CONCENTRATE ON THE CARD
THAT REACHES YOU THE DEEPEST.
AND I'M GOING TO TRY TO SEE
WHICH ONE YOU'RE SENDING ME.
♪ ♪
[AUDIENCE CHEERS, APPLAUDS].
JASON: WHO CHOSE
THE WAVY LINES?
DID YOU PICK
THAT ONE, TOO?
JUDGING BY THE SHOW OF HANDS,
MARC'S PREDICTION MATCHES
THE CHOICE OF OVER HALF OF
OUR FANS IN TIMES SQUARE!
MARC: HEY JASON, OVER HERE.
JASON: HEY!
MARC: HOW ARE YOU DOING?
JASON: HOW DID YOU DO THAT?
MARC: YOUR MIND IS CAPABLE
OF ALL SORTS OF COOL THINGS.
JASON: I CAN SEE THAT,
BUT CAN YOU TELL ME WHAT THE
MECHANICS WERE
BEHIND THE TRICK?
MARC: WELL, NO I
CAN'T TELL YOU THAT.
JASON: NO?
MARC: WE'RE PUBLIC
AND EVERYTHING.
LOOK, LOOK, LOOK, IF
THEY TURN OFF THE AUDIO.
IN FACT, I'LL MAKE SURE
THE AUDIO GOES OFF AND I'LL
EXPLAIN ALL THIS STUFF TO YOU.
JASON: AS THE
LAST HOUR HAS SHOWN,
WE MAY NOT YET TELEPATHICALLY
COMMUNICATE BRAIN-TO-BRAIN,
BUT WE CAN ABSOLUTELY
LISTEN AND PAY BETTER ATTENTION
TO THE SIGNALS WE GET
FROM OUR OWN BRAINS.
SHIRA: THIS ONE FEELS
A LITTLE BIT HEAVIER?
FARAH: (BLEEP), IT'S SO HARD!
MAN: YO, THAT'S (BLEEP)!
WHAT?!
JASON: YOUR INTERNAL
GUIDANCE SYSTEM COMMANDS SOME
PRETTY INCREDIBLE
MISSIONS EACH AND EVERY DAY.
FROM HELPING US
PERFORM SUPERHUMAN FEATS.
TO TRICKING OURSELVES INTO
BELIEVING THE IMPOSSIBLE.
JESSE: IT FEELS LIKE MY
NOSE IS GETTING BIGGER.
JASON: TO MAKING SENSE OF
THE AVALANCHE OF INPUT LAYERED
INTO EVERY FACET OF OUR WORLD.
YOUR "AUTO-PILOT" IS A
PRETTY ACCOMPLISHED NAVIGATOR.
DON'T FORGET TO
ENJOY THE RIDE.